there's kind of a pushback in silicon
valley a little bit against hard work
can you speak to the sort of
the thing you admire to see the new guy
working so hard that thing what is the
value of that thing in a company see
this is i like just to be very frank it
drives me nuts like
i saw this really funny video on tick
tock was it on tick tock it was like i'm
taking a break from my mental health to
work on my career i thought that was
funny
um
[Laughter]
so it's like oh it is kind of phrased
that way the opposite often right yeah
um okay so a couple things
uh
i
uh
i have worked so hard
to do the things that i did like mike
and i lost years off of our lives
staying up late figuring things out
the stress that comes with the job i
have a lot more gray hair now than i did
back then
it requires an enormous amount of work
and most people aren't successful right
but even the ones that do don't skate by
um
i am okay if people choose not to work
hard because i don't actually think
there's anything in this world that says
you have to work hard
but i do think that great things require
a lot of hard work so there's no way you
can expect to change the world without
working really hard and by the way
even changing the world
you know the folks that i respect the
most have nudged the world in like a
slight direction
slight
very very slight
like
even if elon accomplishes all the things
he wants to accomplish we will have i
have nudged the world in a slight
direction but it requires enormous
amount there was an interview with him
where he was just like
he was interviewed i think at the tesla
factory and he was like
work is really hard this is actually
unhealthy
and i can't recall the exact but he was
like visibly shaken about how hard he
had been working and he was like this is
bad
and unfortunately i think to have great
outcomes you actually do need to work at
like three standard deviations above the
mean
but there's nothing saying that people
have to go for that see the thing is but
what i would argue this is my personal
opinion is nobody has to do anything
first of all exactly they certainly
don't have to work hard exactly but
i think
hard work in a company should be admired
i treat i do too and you should not feel
like
you shouldn't feel good about yourself
for not working hard
like
so for example i don't have to work out
i don't have to
run
i hate running
but like i certainly don't feel good if
i don't run because i know for my health
like there's certain values i guess is
what i'm trying to get right the the
certain values that you have in life it
feels like there's certain values that
companies should have and hard work is
one of the things um
i think that should be admired i often
ask this kind of silly question
uh just just to get a sense of people
one that like if i'm hiring and so on i
just ask if they
think it's better to work hard or work
smart
it was helpful for me to
get a sense of people from that
because you think like the right both
was that the answer was the answer's
both i usually try not to give them that
but sometimes i'll say both if that's an
option but a lot of people kind of
a surprising number will say work smart
and they're usually people who don't
know how to work smart
and they're they're literally just lazy
and not just there's two there's two
effects behind that it's one is laziness
and the other
is
ego
when you're younger and you say it's
better to work smart
it means
you think you know what it means to work
smart at this early stage
to me people that say work hard or both
they have the humility to understand
like i'm going to have to work my ass
off because i'm too dumb to know how to
work smart and people who are
self-critical in this way in some small
amount you have to have some confidence
but
you have if you have humility that means
you're going to actually eventually
figure out what it means to work smart
and then to actually be successful you
should do both so
i have a very particular take on this
which is that um
no one's forcing you to do anything all
choices have consequences
so
if you major in i don't know theoretical
literature i i don't even know if that's
a major i'm just making something up as
opposed to regular literature like but
like literature yeah think about like
like theoretical
yeah
spanish lit from the 14th century like
just make make up your esoteric thing
and then the number of people i went to
stanford with who get out in the world
they're like wait what i can't find a
job like no one wants a theoretical like
there are plenty of counter examples of
people have majored in esoteric things
and gone on to be very successful so i
just want to be clear it's not about the
major but
every choice you make
whether it's to have kids like
i love my children it's so awesome to
have two kids and it is so hard to work
really hard and also have kids it's
really hard and there's a reason why
certain very successful people like
don't have are not successful but people
who run very very large companies or
startups
have chosen not to have kids for a while
or choose not to like prioritize them
everything's a choice and like i choose
to prioritize my children because like i
want to do that right
so everything's a choice
now once you've made that choice
i think it's important that the contract
is clear which is to say let's imagine
you were joining a new startup
it's important that that startup
communicate that like the expectation is
like we're all working really really
hard right now you don't have to join
the startup
but like if you do just know like you're
it's almost as if you join i don't know
pick your uh
pick your pick your like sports team
like let's go back to the yankees for a
second
you want to join the yankees but you
don't really want to work that hard you
don't really want to do batting practice
or pitching practice or whatever for
your position right
um
that to me is wacko and that's actually
the world that it feels like we live in
in tech sometimes where people both want
to work for the yankees because it pays
a lot but like don't actually want to
work that hard
that i don't fully understand because if
you sign up for some of these things
just sign up for it but it's okay if you
don't want to sign up for it there's so
many wonderful careers in this world
that don't require 80 hours a week but
when i read about companies going to
like four day work weeks and stuff i
just like i chuckle because i can't get
enough done with a seven day week i
don't know how
and people will say oh you're just not
working smart and it's like no i i work
pretty smart i think in general like i i
wouldn't have gotten to this point if i
hadn't like some amount of working smart
and there is balance though so i used to
be like a pretty big cyclist i don't do
it much anymore just because of kids and
like prioritizing other things right
but one of the most important things to
learn as a cyclist is to take a rest day
but to me and to cyclists like resting
is a function
of optimizing for the long run
it's not like a thing that you do for
its own merits
it's actually like if you don't rest
your muscles don't recover and then
you're just not as like you're not
training as efficiently you should
probably
the the successful people have known in
terms of athletes they hate rest days
but they know they have to do it for the
long term like absolutely they think
their opposition is getting stronger and
stronger and that's the the feeling but
you know it's the right thing and
usually you need a coach to help you
yeah totally so i mean i use this thing
called training peaks and it's
interesting because it actually
mathematically shows like where you are
on the curve and all this stuff yeah but
you have to re like you have to have
that rest but it it's a function of
going harder for longer again it's this
reinforcement learning like planning the
aggregate and long but a lot of people
will hide behind laziness by saying that
they're trying to optimize for the long
run and they're not they're just not
working very hard but again you don't
have to sign up for it it's totally cool
like i don't think less of people for
like not working super hard just like
don't sign up for things that require
working super hard and some of that
requires for the leadership to have the
guts the boldness to communicate
effectively at the very beginning i mean
sometimes i think
most of the problems arise from the fact
that the
leadership is kind of hesitant
to to communicate this the socially
um difficult
truth of what it takes to be
at this company so they kind of say hey
come come with us there's we have snacks
you know
but unlimited vacation and yeah you know
uh ray at bridgewater is always
fascinating because you know people
it's been called like a cult on the
outside or cultish and
but what's fascinating is like they just
don't give on their principles they're
like listen this is what it's like to
work here we record every meeting
we're like brutally honest and that's
not going to feel right to everyone and
if it doesn't feel regular totally cool
just go work somewhere else but if you
work here you are signing up for this
and that's that's been fascinating to me
because it's honesty up front it's a
system in which you
operate
um and if it's not for you like no one's
forcing you to work there right
you